hey guys down bring the etherion a Jon
Snow and the near Targaryen would marry
in the upcoming season a theory that I
personally wouldn't like to happen
considering that John is the Nemesis
nephew which just sounds so wrong even
though instance it's kind of a normal
thing in Game of Thrones not to mention
in Targaryen family while I wouldn't
like it there are a lot of facts that
are pointing on this marriage a lot of
reasons that I'll introduce you with in
this video after six seasons Daenerys
Targaryen has finally began her journey
across the Narrow Sea
his final set sail for Westeros with an
impressive fleet formed of her armies
and her allies along with her three
large dragons a move that has been in
the making since the very first season a
move that will doubtlessly change the
political playing field of Westeros
however before they equally murine she
had to leave someone behind
her lawyer protect her with benefits
Darrien hearts her reasons for leaving
him in Mereen were just because she
needed someone she can trust rolled over
the city and to ensure that it doesn't
fall back into slavery while she is
across the Narrow Sea but more important
reason for leaving him is in the fact
that the mother of dragons is looking
for potential suitors in Westeros which
would provide her a new alliance which
will later one step further in
conquering the Iron Throne the most
important reason for that scene image
Danny broke up with Arya was included in
the finale to foreshadow the most
important marriage in Game of Thrones
series that have ever happened or is
going to happen the most powerful
alliance in Westeros that will be most
likely forged at some point in season 7
the nurse is coming to Westeros with her
houses words precisely she's coming with
fire and blood with the strongest army
the world has seen since the fall of
Illyria which makes her path to
conquering the Seven Kingdoms quite
easier but Danny doesn't want only to
conquer it she wants to build a stable
order wants to reunite all Seven
Kingdoms of which most are in an open
rebellion against the crown which
requires the support of the great Lords
of Westeros most of the great lords of
Seven Kingdoms feels to know our dad
replaced by a new generation or Lee - no
one at all by
to reach for an example which has no
lords now that the Tyrells are essential
extinguished and the Stormlands who also
have no Lord either since the Bharati
ons are dead Cersei and Jaime will rule
House Lannister and the Westar ones
together the Martell's or should I say
the sand snakes beside their own woman
they have already become Danny's Ally
which eliminates them as one of them is
possible suitors as well the river once
belonged to house Frey but
Arya took care of it in the season six
finale by killing the head of the house
along with his two sons
even though Walder still has many heirs
in my opinion the Power Balance will
swing back to house Tully with Admiral
Nick's head who also has a wife and a
child
meaning that besides him being ill was a
life for Danny he's also not a possible
suitor there are only three Lords that
don't have a voice but are shaving a
power those three feeding candidates for
the nearest are your own Greyjoy the
king of the Iron Islands who has no wife
so this is a power and probably this
point she has a huge iron fleet but
there won't be a marriage between those
two since the nearest promised to kill
urine and said Yara is the queen of the
Iron Islands the second candidate for
marrying the mother of dragons is the
Lord of the Vale
Robin who has the strongest army in the
Seven Kingdoms but he is too young
manipulated by Littlefinger and also his
army should be under commands of the
king in the north which make Jon Snow
even a better match for Dany the only
logical choice for Daenerys ain't the
only one that major amount of fans are
already shipping is a marriage between
the mother of dragons and the king in
the north
not only the John is the only logical
option since as a king John is the
second most powerful person in Seven
Kingdoms one of a few men who actually
has any authority and the man that also
controls an army of stark loyalists who
will fight beside Jon Snow to the bitter
end
but their pairing with also fulfilling
an should pack the teen goes to houses a
bag that is dating all the way back
before Eris's madness all the way back
to the Civil War Between the Targaryen
snown as the dance of the Dragons
morning Michelle stark supported the
claim of a queen rhaenyra targaryen
apparel sustained with the condition in
which Targaryen a royal princess would
marry a star
this Agreement known as bag of ice and
fire was never fulfilled but it could
change in the upcoming season since the
nares doesn't want only to conquer the
Seven Kingdoms but wants to make it a
better place wants to build a stable
structure marrying the Jon Snow would
bring her support and control over the
kingdom that is large as the other six
combined the nearest already has one of
the strongest military forces by the sea
and strongest by air which means that
this marriage would also provider the
biggest army on the land as well since
she already has her two big armies and
the huge army provided by her allies I
understand your concerns about accuracy
of this theory since Jon know that all
the lords should stop fighting between
each other and unite all their armies to
stand a chance against the untamed army
but John also understands that research
the Lannister on the Iron Throne it will
be impossible to do then evolves we
haven't thrown and John wants to build
an army to defeat White Walkers and
their white horde but neither will
happen without the others help I don't
expect this marriage to happen until the
very end of season seven since we all
know Jon Snow's personality and we know
the general multiplied to give search a
chance to stop fighting in to join her
army to the greatest cause but upon
realizing that Cersei whole probably at
this point also be married to urine will
represent a huge stress for the living
side Jon will decide to bring her rein
to an end and that's in my opinion the
moment in which John and Danny will join
their forces they will marry each other
with this political marriage in my
opinion there will also be a pact and
agreement in the jungle have Daenerys to
Vindhya and throne and stop search this
madness but it's time for good whereupon
they're going to prepare for the
greatest battle without any threat
behind from the links side with an
official confirmation then John is
actually son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark it places the nurses John's
n but that's nothing new in Game of
Thrones world we've seen worse than that
we've seen a brother and sister having
intimate relations what's also important
to highlight that incestuous pairings
have never bothered to Ariens Targaryen
spent over three hundred years betting
brother to sister in order to keep their
bloodline pure which means that Union
between an end and her nephews seems fit
in the
almost possibility even though they
probably want to do that they would know
the true John's identity but no one else
that John is cattle garyun no one else
keeps true identity now on the brain who
will arrive at Winterfell and won't have
a chance to real the truth to John the
John will be sharing to Dragonstone at a
time of brand's arrival there's one more
person beside brand at normal John's to
identity its Howland Reed
meanors father who is the only man that
survived a fight against her arch pain
and at the same time segment from a
certain death Howland Reed the man that
was the first to charge against the
sword of the morning whereupon she was
slashed across the chest by Dane and
almost died but also the man who saved
man from a certain death save Ned Stark
who gave his best but couldn't say the
chance against her are today in superior
fighting skills and got himself disarmed
this same man the Lord of greywater
watch the father of Meera and Jojen Reed
will resolve how stark Colin Reed who
displayed very important role in star's
life with saving man from a certain
death is playing a very important role
because he's not his children bran
probably wouldn't have even become a
three-eyed Raven in addition he would
probably be dead and they'll play a huge
role because I'm expecting him from
showrunners to bring Howland Reed in the
show along with a few explanations for
example what was how I'm doing while his
son died for Ned's son and while his
daughters still be on the wall
protecting Brad but yeah beside bran and
Holland no one else John Stehr identity
he's still known as a star bastard and
the king in the north
which beside increasing a possibility of
this marriage also might be a problem
since Starks and Targaryen haven't had a
friendly relationship out to the Mad
King then his father and John's
grandfather brutally killed Ned Stark's
father who protested against ragaar
scheme at over his daughter leiana and
also killed Ned's brother Brandon who
have sought blooded known as the Volvo
who upon finding out about wrecker
section Road King's Landing immediately
with his squire only brave and fearless
Brandon upon entering the red keep
shouted for eager to come out and die
but Rhaegar wasn't there leading to
Brandon and his few companions getting
rested by Ares to match king
whereupon he forged random to watch as
his father was burned alive in his own
armor while Brandon strangled himself
while attempting to get to his sword in
order to save his father violence was
mad and killed John's uncle and
grandfather along with any good
relationships to the stars
I don't think it's going to be a big
issue for Danny's and John's marriage
the nearest know that your father was
known as the Mad King meaning that she
doesn't have anything against Kyle Stark
while John as the current head of House
Stark also most likely doesn't have a
reason to hate our gariands since the
nearest is nothing to do with your
father since let me also highlight one
detail one sentence from the leaked plot
a sentence which I personally wouldn't
like to happen a sentence which says
that Jon Snow and the nearest are going
to have intimate relations one about
while heading north which would be so
wrong and weird at least for me because
they all know and as I've already said a
few times
Johnny's Danny's nephew a [ __ ] which they
don't and at that point won't know so
it's not their fault but also it's not
surprising for Game of Thrones world not
to mention for House Targaryen in
conclusion this marriage would make
their goals come true to both of them
Danny would avenge her family and would
sit on the Iron Throne while John would
get rid of the biggest villains and the
biggest threat for doing side since its
Cersei and yearn alive John won't be
able to unite all arms together and if
all armed so Westeros wouldn't unite
divided wrestlers wouldn't stand a
chance against the undead army let me
know your opinion and all of this in the
comment section down below I'm curious
what your thoughts are about this
political marriage is it just me : it's
wrong and weird but at the same time
this say marriage seems to be more than
required since divides Westeros won't
stand a chance
once the White Walkers in the right
horde cross or even knock the wall down
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next one peace
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]